at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking
[Music]
this episode of the Tim Farriss shows
brought to you by athletic greens I get
us all the time
if I could only take one supplement what
would it be the answer is inevitably
athletic greens I view it as and a lot
of you now view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance I recommended it
way back in 2010 in the 4-hour body and
I did not get paid to do so I've been
using it since before that and I use it
in a lot of different ways I travel with
it to avoid getting sick or to help
mitigate the likelihood of getting sick
I take it in the morning to ensure
optimal performance and overall it
covers my bases if I can't get what I
need from whole food meals throughout
the rest of the day and if you want to
give athletic greens a try they're
offering a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I nearly always travel
with at least three or four of these one
dose bags in other words if you buy
athletic greens as a first-time buyer
you now get for a limited time and extra
$79 in free product so check out the
details at athletic greens comm forward
slash Tim again that's athletic greens
dot-com forward slash Tim for your free
travel pack with any purchase
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin's hello Monday hello Monday is
a podcast
hello Monday with Jessy Hempel is back
for season two and the show is full of
advice practical tactical advice that
you can start using today each week
Jessi sits down with featured guests to
investigate the role work plays in their
lives how it can be integrated into your
life and how to make work work for you
better this season one of the first
episodes is with Jerry Colonna who has
been called the CEO whisperer I've
actually done quite a bit of work with
Jerry and he is one of the world's most
in-demand executive coaches amongst the
startup ecosystem in the episode Jerry
shares his approach to meetings explains
how to ask good open-ended questions and
he also goes through his approach to
daily journaling among other things
journaling can really create an
incredible competitive advantage and
also act as an emotional rebalancing
tool of sorts so I recommend taking a
look at it giving a listen more
accurately so whether you're starting
your first job or gearing up for
retirement
hello Monday helps you tackle Monday and
the rest of the work week with tactics
and strategies that you can use so check
it out find hello Monday with Jesse
Hempel that's jess85 I own Apple
podcasts or wherever you listen to
podcasts
well hello boys and girls this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show or it is my job
every episode to attempt to deconstruct
world-class performers of all different
types to tease out the routines favorite
books habits and so on that you may
apply to your own life my guest this
episode is ben horowitz
you can find him on twitter at be
horowitz hor o w itz ben is a co-founder
and general partner at the venture
capital firm andreessen horowitz he is
the author of The New York Times best
seller the hard thing about hard things
and the brand-new Harper business book
what you do is who you are he also
created the a 16 Z cultural leadership
fund if you are wondering what a 16 Z
stands for just count the number of
letters between the beginning and the
end of andreessen horowitz so he created
the a 16 Z cultural leadership fund to
connect cultural leaders to the best new
technology companies and enable more
young African Americans to enter the
technology industry prior to a 16 Z
that's Andrews and Horowitz Ben was
co-founder and CEO of Opsware formerly
known as loud cloud which was acquired
by hewlett-packard for 1.6 billion
dollars in 2007 previously been ran
several product divisions at Netscape
Communications including the widely
acclaimed directory and security product
line he has an MS and BA in computer
science from UCLA and Columbia
University respectively so without
further ado please enjoy this
wide-ranging conversation with the one
and only Ben Horowitz
Ben welcome to the show thanks Tim very
excited to be here and I have so many
questions I have pages and pages of
questions we'll try to get to as many as
possible I thought I would start with a
name that I know you're familiar with
and that is Andy Grove that may not be a
name that all people know but could you
please describe who Andy is why he's
interesting to you yeah so Andy was kind
of one of the founders of Intel which is
kind of the foundational company of
Silicon Valley um if there was any and
in foundations all not only
technologically but also culturally I
think importantly and just an amazing
guy probably you know for my money the
best CEO we ever had out here but you
know he started his life he was a
refugee from Hungary from World War two
and you know he had to escape the Nazis
and then the Communists and kind of came
over on a boat and with I forgot they
gave him like $27 when he got to New
York and he taught himself English and
he kind of went to school at CCNY and
became a physicist and then you know
eventually met up with Bob Noyce he
actually told me a very funny story
towards the end of his life where Gordon
Moore who was the you know the famous
Moore's Law and founder also a
co-founder of Intel when they brought
Andy in to Fairchild Semiconductor the
way they picked him out and and he told
me who's very light he said he finished
his PhD at Berkeley in two and a half
years and they and Gordon Moore had
found that people have finished their
PhD quickly correlate with high
performers so that's how he got the job
well that's perfect jumping off point
for about a half a dozen things that I
was meaning to get to anyway but let's
I'll try to Ratchet back my my caffeine
enthusiasm and and focus on Andy
for a bit longer high output management
you wrote the foreword to a reprint of
that book which when I lived in Silicon
Valley I was able to observe the the the
rebirth of sort of the resurgence of
this book and its popularity and I know
some incredible founders who have stacks
of this book in their offices to give
away why did you agree or offer to write
the foreword and what are some of the
takeaways that people might find in that
book or that you found a particular
value yeah well you know it was my
favorite management book by far in fact
I think it might have been the only
management book that I ever read that I
liked so it was you know quite a thing
for me when Andy called me and he said
Ben you know I was watching you give
this talk at Stanford and you know in
the talk I was talking about my book my
first book the hard thing about hard
things and somebody asked me why I wrote
it I said well you know when I was a kid
I read this book high output management
and it like it was amazing because it's
the CEO of Intel which is like the most
important company in technology and he
wrote this book and it wasn't to like
you know say how great he was
really gonna like all these books that
these guys write who you know run big
companies and how like they here's what
I learned the value of a dollar and then
this is when I'd be built a great big
company and all this kind of thing they
say but it was a book to teach like
young people like myself how to manage
so it was just a complete contribution
back to the environment with really you
know in a way nothing in it for him and
you know I always when I'm in reading
that book I said well if I ever make it
if I ever kind of become anybody that
anybody wants to listen to I'm gonna
write the sequel to high output
management and that was I tried to do
with the hard thing about her things
when he called me you know there was no
question I was like 100% I'll write the
foreword but the reason it was such a
great book is it was kind of the
original hard thing about hard things
and that most management books are like
here's all the obvious easy stuff and
here's like eight like random steps to
do the
easiest thing in the world that anybody
could figure out like who you know
wasn't like an idiot but a negro it was
like he went all the way like right to
the worst hardest most messed up things
that you'd have to do so like you know
one of the things I remember from the
book is he goes well hey look you're
writing performance review and the rule
of thumb is you never put anything in
the read performance review that you
haven't already told the employee right
yeah and and we're really like it that's
the rule that's what we do and he's like
okay so now you're at the performance
review and there's something that the
employee needs to improve that you
haven't told them what do you do and
it's like okay that's it that's a real
like thing and it's like you put in the
reviewer do you not put it in the review
and you know his thing is you got to put
in the review and like it's bad they
didn't tell him but it's worse to not
tell him now and you know and those
kinds of difficult decisions like you
know how you really do that or like you
know it's like okay you know people are
late to meetings you know they're
wasting everybody's time so stealing
money from the company like but like
it's very awkward to deal with them and
so how do you deal with am i mad and
that kind of thing which is really what
you need to know to put any of these
management techniques into effect this
like how do you do it when there's real
conflict and you know that's why it's
such it's just just an amazing book so
you mentioned the the coming to meetings
late and then in one of your blog posts
you have so you have some fantastic blog
posts an excellent writing both of
course on the web in this case and then
in the books but that you you share an
anecdote that begins with a for example
we could talk about sort of wartime
versus peacetime CEOs but a basic
principle in most management books is
that you should never embarrass an
employee in a public setting but Andy
Grove in the situation that you just
mentioned once said to an employee who
entered a meeting late quote all I have
in this world is time and you're wasting
my time
and you have to realize when he said
that like he was like God so it was like
God he's gotta been doing like your work
it's like God telling you video ways
so I suppose the the first question that
I'd like to ask and we may end up
getting into the war time versus
peacetime CEO differentiation but what
occurs to me is that he has he has a
scientific background he's an
engineering and physics background you
also have a computer science background
how do you think about management what
is it and I know this is a very broad
question but do you think about
management differently than many people
I would seem to be that the answer is
yes
also just based on the observation you
had about most management books which I
would agree with how is your experience
your life experience maybe including
computer science informed how you
approach or think about management well
I think it's you know it's an
interesting combination because there's
a part of an engineering background
that's extremely helpful which is you
know can you think about systems and can
you think about like how like broad
scale systems interactions occur and
like what the implications are and then
there's a different part which is a very
kind of I would say high EQ component
which is in order to make that system
work you have to be able to see the
company through the eyes of the people
who are doing the work which are usually
the people are not in the room when
you're making the decision and you have
to understand how it's going to affect
them how it's going to change their
behavior and so forth you know just so
as an example of that like you know it's
easy like if somebody comes to you and
they say you know Ben I really deserve a
raise and you could go okay well you
know like I like you and I want you to
like me so I'll give you that raise but
you have to think about you know if
you're bad at all you go okay well like
how will it look to the people who are
not here is that fair have they gotten a
chance at it is this person just getting
the raise because he came into my office
or alike you know does he really deserve
it so do I have a systematic process to
Valley
a talent and allocate the money that we
have or do I rent it like that because
I'm not really thinking about it from
everybody else's perspective and so you
kind of end up needing both to be good
at it and I think you know kind of going
back to Andy screaming at that employee
that that's kind of a little bit in the
balance right because you know that
employees definitely gonna be like
ashamed and horrified and maybe
demotivated by him publicly embarrassing
him but in that instance what he was
doing was something different which was
he was setting the culture and saying
look culturally fundamentally like I'm
gonna teach everybody in this company a
lesson by saying something that's so
powerful and so colorful that it's going
to spread like wildfire through my
company and everybody's going to know
that it's not okay to waste people's
time by being late for a meeting and
that's more important in this case than
the individual so it gets you know it's
kind of a Confucian approach they're
good at the individual must be
sacrificed for the good of the whole and
you have to do that as CEO from time to
time now you don't want to do it
gratuitously because that is definitely
going to hurt somebody's feelings so you
know and and maybe that's a a great
employee or whatever but you do you know
and particularly if the culture is in
place and they're kind of willfully
ignoring the culture which I you know I
believe is the case in this case then
you have to kind of value the system and
value that above that person's feelings
and these are kind of the trade-offs
that you make in management and that's
why it is complicated to get it right
and why I like it's not you know it's
always like broken down and management
books are often it's like you're talking
to one person at a time and that's never
the case you always talk to everybody if
this is a useful distinction I'd love
for you to define the two terms for us
or the differences between two terms
that is management and leadership how do
you how do you distinguish between those
two I know it seems like a stupid
question maybe but yeah but if I'd love
for you to if you're able to just
comment on that for a second or if it's
a bad question week
move on I mean I think a lot of
leadership is or the way I think about
it and you know then they're kind of you
know we're you know my own dictionary
that is you know leadership there's kind
of a is a lot of getting is the art of
kind of getting people to follow you and
as Colin Powell said you know if only
out of curiosity and I think so that
that involves kind of you know having a
vision being able to articulate it being
inspiring making you know creating a
feeling among people that you that you
care about them in a way and you care
about you know their goals and
objectives and and you know what they
want out of life and people want to
follow people who have you know some
number of those attributes management
gets more into okay you have this great
vision you've articulated everybody
likes it but like how do you
operationalize that how do you kind of
break it down into its steps how do you
make sure that people who need to
communicate are communicating in these
kinds of things so it's kind of you know
leader a lot of leadership is you know
knowing what to do getting people to
follow you and then you know management
involves getting people to do what you
know and that's a kind of a little bit
of different part of your brain it's you
know leadership so a little more on the
creative side management's you know it
requires a little more discipline and
systematization on the on the on the
former in the case of leadership getting
people to follow you if only out of
curiosity and that and this may may not
be a fit but in the course of doing
research for this conversation I came
across mention of a paper called good
product manager bad product yeah and it
seems like at least the way it was
phrased in this fortune piece it'd be
quote became a Bible for the startups in
this case referring to Netscape
for the startups unpolished young
executives so could you describe that
paper and what impact it had on you
and/or the people around you and it came
out yeah so you know it's funny is it
was a piece I wrote out of pure
frustration so who turns out like
product manager is a weird job in
Silicon Valley in that in every single
company it means something different you
know and so like what you do is that
doesn't really translate well from one
company to a next and many companies
have just bad product management
functions and so you know the people
that I kind of inherited when I got the
job to run the team all had these like
different and differing and weird views
on what the job was and I you know I
always found myself like yelling at them
going like does that make any sense to
you that kind of thing you know like I
was like at that level of frustration
and then you know one day I was just
like you know I have to train like the
team on what I want and I was like but I
don't have time to put a training
program together so I sat down I just
wrote this document good product manager
bad product manager and the thing I had
my you know head was like and it's a bad
thought but it was like this is gonna be
like dog training you know like that's
where the name came from but it was
really just you know like like this is
what good product managers do and this
is what bad product managers do and just
like let's just be clear on that so like
you'll know you can anticipate what I'm
gonna say if you do something bad and
and we don't have to have that
conversation all the time and so that
that's all it started out to be and then
what happened was kind of as you know as
you said is like people valued just
getting that information so much that
not only did my team use it but then
everybody at Netscape started using it
and then like you know a huge number of
people you know product managers in
Silicon Valley still like refer to that
thing which I
1995 and what it taught me was like
everybody no matter how smart they are
no matter like they went to Stanford or
Harvard or whatever they can always use
training in the job that you want them
to do because the job that you need them
to do is one these jobs are very complex
and they you know and and they're
different and and a lot of it is what do
you expect as a manager and so if your
manager doesn't train your people you
probably I can't imagine you're good at
your job just because there's no way
they're going to be able to read your
mind on everything so I'd like to talk
about more lessons learned and then I'm
going to segue from that into how you
might teach others because in a lot of
ways you do teach others let's let's
chat about Bill Campbell and Bill
Campbell has come up once before on this
podcast when I had a conversation with
Eric Schmidt a legendary figure known
throughout the valley as coach as has
advised people like Jeff Bezos Steve
Jobs and so on
could you share what your relationship
was like with Bill and what some of the
things or any of the things that you
that you really absorbed from Bill yeah
so you know I mean he was just such a
great help to me as CEO and a lot of it
was just you know being able to have a
conversation with somebody who knew what
I was talking about and and who knew
what they were talking about you know at
the same time which is when you're CEO
it's just very difficult to have those
in a way you know that's kind of
confidential and and like not with like
somebody who could like remove you and
that kind of thing and so he was just
invaluable to me in that sense and and a
lot of what was so great about him is
you know we could sew on the one hand
like we could
argue about whatever and like he would
have been put in like maybe I would you
know listen to it maybe I went but it
would never whatever I did never
affected the relationship you know it
was just that kind of thing with him but
the thing that he did better than
anybody that I've worked with is he
could really see the company through the
employee like through the eyes of every
single employee he knew how people would
react to every single decision and you
know and he wasn't even running the
company who just come in once in a while
and so forth he'd know enough people in
it he would but he had just like this
incredible sense about that and in that
you know and that just proved to be very
valuable so I'll give you an example so
you know we had done this giant deal
with EDS to sell them kind of our old we
had this business that was gonna kind of
basically make us bankrupt and by doing
the transaction with EDS we kind of
escaped bankruptcy and then kind of
launched into this other business the
software business which eventually
became like worth like 1.6 billion
dollars there I think that was it and
you know so it was like the probably the
most important deal we'd ever done as a
company and you know we do the deal and
I go bill like you know we got the deal
done I can't believe it you know we're
gonna announce it you know you go to New
York on Monday and we're gonna announce
it and he's like no no no you can't go
and I was like well why can't I go and
he's like well like when you do the deal
right like this deals can involve
selling some employees to them laying
some people off and so forth as soon as
that news hits you got to be in person
in the company talking to the employees
and letting everybody know where they
stand as quickly as possible and I was
like oh of course he's ready you know I
didn't even liked thought that through
and had I not done that you know I so I
did that I sent mark to New York to do
the announcement but I had I not done
that had I not kind of stayed back and
had that conversation I don't think we
would have made it as a company because
that day ended up being pivotal you know
to reconstructing the trust that I
needed to kind of run the company going
forward and you know that
that's the kind of value that bill added
but I you know if you want to like know
he is the only person I've ever met
who's like could do the thing that bill
could do is Oprah Winfrey mmm and I know
that sounds probably weird in a way but
like Oprah Winfrey can like meet you and
talk to you for five minutes
and she can know you as well as
somebody's known you ten years and Bill
could do that too that's so Alton yeah
and then you may have run into something
like that but it is amazing
what what do you think is behind that is
it an ability to see behind the words
and just deeply empathically sense more
about your core personality and what's
shaped it than other people what allows
an Oprah for instance to do that do you
do you have any any theories yeah so
it's definitely a combination of things
that I don't possess so it's a little
hard to read it but you know yes she
kind of can read in every signal your
Senate so like the tone of your voice
the expression on your face like the way
you're holding your hands everything
like is complete high fidelity
information to her and then she knows
the exact right question to ask to get
to the deeper level of what's going on
and I you know like I've seen her do it
I seen bill do it I learned from it but
like I I like literally don't have the
capacity to do it anywhere near their
level but yeah it's some combination of
like they're able to just process way
way more information about a person much
much faster and then great retention on
like the thousand people they've met
before that might match to that and it
is super impressive oh yeah there is
it's it's I enjoy trying to deconstruct
the secret sauce but sometimes it is
just impossible to do I mean there's
magic yeah there are certain people who
are hard-wired for a
a different spectrum of perception on
the other hand there are a lot of
coachable or teachable skills and if
we're if we're looking at management I'd
like to shift from in some respect
student of Bill or advice receiver of
Bill Campbell to advice giver and Mark
Zuckerberg has said that you are the
management guru to all of the young
entrepreneurs in the valley and I want
to I want to dig into that for a second
because of course you have much faster
experience than I do but having spent
almost 20 years in Silicon Valley before
moving spent a lot of time with
first-time startup founders who in some
cases have a real tiger by the tail and
many of these CEOs are really great
product people with no real management
experience to speak of who have never
had this type of game to lose if that
makes sense what would you teach her
what do you teach or advise someone like
that if you have say a first afternoon
meeting with them or a few hours there a
new portfolio company in walks this
bewildered CEO who's entering deep
waters how do you how do you begin to
cultivate them or advise them as a
manager in training so to speak or a CEO
in training yes a you know they're all
different but there's things that are
similar about them you know and some of
them are good at some things and others
about others so I I don't know that
there's a kind of thing that I would say
to any of them but you know one thing
they all struggle with is how to build
their team you know particularly their
management team and and kind of when
what you're speaking about okay like
it's different if you know they're not
succeeding or whatever but if they're
succeeding and like the company's kind
of degenerating because they don't know
how to run it then that usually kind of
gets into this whole executive higher
integrating managing problem and this is
first of all none of them are good at it
like we've never had a first-time CEO
who is good at this and I know I wasn't
good at it when I started and the
problem is okay you know your board goes
hey you need to hire like a CFO like you
know somebody's got to keep track this
place it's it's going crazy like what
are you doing okay I'm gonna hire a CFO
and okay and you go well I'm the CEO so
I must know how to do that but you don't
know how to do that and not like that
like you've never worked in a finance
organization you don't even know what
the CFO job is like always ask my it's
like you know what's a good control
structure how do you distinguish a good
one from a bad one you know like it may
have no idea like and so like how are
they going to interview a CFO it's sort
of like interviewing a Japanese
interpreter if you don't know Japanese
they're all sound wonderful
right now I'm gonna I'm gonna plead
ignorance before we get too deep into
the weeds what is a control structure in
this context yeah so you know just how
does money get spent you know like do
you know every dollar that's getting
spent you know when money comes in like
do you account for it properly these
kinds of things and how do you do that
systematically as the company grows and
you know people have budgets and all
these kinds of things so you get you
know so this so it's just something that
they don't know how to do and they don't
know how to ask say that they don't know
how to do it and they don't know how to
kind of learn how to do it and so I
always like to just start with okay like
let's talk about a process for learning
how to you know possibly at least get a
criteria for your company for this
position not like a general like you
know the Platonic form of a CFO cuz that
doesn't exist but like a CFO for this
company right now like what do we need
and then we you know how do we do that
well maybe we should talk to some CFO's
see what they would hire for us see if
that matches us you know see how they
would test for it in an interview and
that you know kind of get deeper into it
but even as you go through all that like
you know then you okay
that CFO get signed how do you teach
them about your company you know what is
day one look like how do you integrate
them these kinds of things so it's you
know it really is kind of has to be a
hand over hand instruction and then like
you know what's there in there if you
hire somebody you know a lot of times
these CEOs will hire somebody who's so
senior and so aggressive you know
because they went for the biggest resume
they could find and the person wants
doesn't want to be CFO they want to be
CEO and then you know that person will
start you know trying to grab territory
from the CEO and all these kinds of
things and you've got politics you've
got a handle and and so that's just a
long I would say it's not a quick manual
it's a kind of ongoing conversation to
understand where they are what they have
to do how to retain their mojo all that
kind of thing
and well I'll start with saying that the
hard thing about hard things your book
one of your books I should say is one of
the most recommended books that has come
up in the last handful of years on this
podcast appreciate by what I would
consider certainly high-performing
founders and CEOs you mentioned or we
mentioned high output management earlier
are there any other books that you would
give to a first-time founder who does
have a tiger by the tail who's who's
doing well but clearly out of their
depth in this in a new level of
complexity with with running what what
is turning into a a company as opposed
to just a a a good product yeah so you
know it's funny people I said like what
are the management books you'd recommend
and I'd be like I don't know so you know
I think that you know and it depends a
little on the leader you know one of the
books that I have been recommending for
years is a book written by CLR James in
seven called the black jacobins which is
the story of the Haitian Revolution and
you go okay what kind of leadership book
is that but it turns out that the you
know that the Toussaint L'Ouverture who
kind of led that revolution was a
basically a management and cultural
genius like better than anybody that
I've ever kind of read about or or
learned from and you know it just ends
up being a great leadership book I think
: Powell's book his autobiography is
very very interesting on leadership and
you know there's a bunch of yeah I think
you know like if it's a little company
Erik Reese's book is great you know the
lean started start yeah I mean amazing
at teaching you things that you know
particularly if you've not built a new
company before or just really
fundamental lessons and we see I mean
you know I will there have been some
things in the news you know lately that
you know about kind of with fad startups
which were kind of all the ones from my
era but you know the the dangers of a
fad startup I think he really
articulates amazingly well in that book
and and that is one of the early traps
you can fall into particularly in an
environment like this where there's a
lot of venture capital money running
around mm-hmm and the the job of CEO you
know I I've enjoyed a lot of your
writing and in one of your blog posts I
think I think the title is making
yourself a CEO at least that's you talk
about how the the job of CEO is a very
unnatural job and right that yeah
and I'm cherry picking here a couple of
lines but to be a good CEO honored to be
liked in the long run you must do many
things that will upset people in the
short run unnatural things
how have you cultivated that ability in
yourself or helped others to cultivate
a willingness to be unpopular in the
short run
I think this at least strikes me is a
real critical differentiator could you
see that yeah so know that is you know
you've hit on probably one of the most
important kind of leadership skills and
you know the easiest way way to think
about it is like if you make decisions
that everybody likes all the time then
those are the decisions they would have
made without you so you're not so almost
by definition you know a lot of the most
important decisions end up being ones
that you know people don't agree with
and don't like and are difficult and
cause people not to like you at least
for a while
and you know the way I generally work
with CEOs on this is because it's very
difficult because you know they're
there's so much emotional psychological
force pushing them to make kind of the
wrong decision the easy decision the one
that is going to be the people-pleasing
decision and a lot of it is just
pointing out what's going to happen
letting them make it and then when the
pain comes go you remember we talked
about this and this is what happens and
you know a lot of it is just you have to
go through making those mistakes to
train yourself to you know it's kind of
like I its running towards the darkness
you know like there's this pain and dark
area where you know like people aren't
going to like you you know it's gonna
suck you know you like maybe you have to
fire somebody maybe have to lay them off
maybe you have to make a very unpopular
decision to cancel a project or whatever
but if you run away from that because
then you always know you have to do it
like you can sense it when you run a
company if you run away from that that's
you know that's when you really get a
huge raging fire that you know both
potentially burn down your company and
it seems to me and if I've never run a
large company but just in my
interactions with various CEOs and
founders that coming back to the CEO
position is a very unnatural
all job that there are there are certain
maybe technical abilities or procedural
abilities maybe that are pretty easily
trained or or relatively straightforward
and then there are others that are
perhaps less explicitly taught and one
that you've written about before is the
ability to manage your own psychology
yes what what tools or techniques have
you personally found or routines
anything at all really to be useful for
cultivating an ability to manage your
own psychology and maybe you could just
describe what that means yeah so I mean
you know like it's it is certainly the
hardest part of the job because what
happens is and you don't think about
this when you're starting a company it's
like one of these and I always talk to
entrepreneurs about this I'm like you
know if you knew what was involved when
you started you would never would have
started they're like absolutely right
there's no way yeah which so it's kind
of a blessing that you don't know
because if you did know then you know
nothing would ever happen but like the
kind of thing that happens is okay you
have this idea to start a company and
then if you just think about that
socially you know like okay so that
you've got a lot of friends and
relatives and like some of them are
excited for you some of them say that's
none we're gonna work and you did it and
you want to prove them wrong and all
that but then you got to go out and
you've got to sell people on the idea so
you've gotta hire people into this kind
of vision that you have and then you've
got to raise money behind it and like
often like some of that money might even
come from like your relatives there that
kind of thing so you've got this money
that people have entrusted you with
you've got careers that people have
entrusted you with and you start going
and then something goes Ryan it looks
like like the company may not work and
so you know what's the consequence of
that well like every relationship you
have you're going to violate if it all
goes down and that is super scary like
it could be
was scary and you know to not let that
thought or that set of thoughts paralyze
you is you know can be really difficult
at times and a lot of it you know first
you know one of the most important
things which I wrote about is first
thing is you you can't think and
probably you know you got to not think
the way investors think in probabilities
you have to just think in terms of how
do I do this
like if there was a way out like which
way is out and train your mind in that
direction as opposed to well there's a
90% chance that like we're not going to
get this deal and if we don't get this
deal we're gonna with the quarter if we
with the quarter we don't be able to
raise money if we won't be able to raise
money then I would have to lay everybody
off like once you start thinking like
that you know you you literally can't
function and so kind of getting around
to okay I've got one bullet in the gun I
have got to hit the target so I'm gonna
get do whatever I can to get as close as
possible and then like we're gonna shoot
our best shot and there's gonna be no
contingency plan and no way out and no
you know like if somehow we don't make
it we don't make it but like we're gonna
die trying and that you know getting to
that mentality is really the key to
being an effective entrepreneur I think
mmm what what have you found to be
helpful for managing the stress of that
type of a sort of existential threat
level one shot one kill psychology are
there any particular habits or types of
self-talk or anything that you use or
encourage that allow people to perform
better under those types of
circumstances well you know like I I
don't want to exaggerate how good I was
at it because you know like I was up at
two o'clock the morning like in a cold
sweat with my guts boiling like all that
stuff like it's not like I didn't have
that right you know
I wasn't that great at it in in terms of
kind of managing it that way but I think
gave me the things that helped me were
one just always focusing on what I could
do like there were so many things I
can't do so many things out of my
control so many things that you know I
mean like I was in the middle of the
greatest technology equity meltdown in
the history of the world so like there
was nothing I could do about that right
although it was hurting me but I just
didn't make any sense to think about
those things so just you know really
thinking about the things that you can
do and then you know Bill Campbell was
very is just very helpful to just be
able to talk to him and you know it
wasn't like he had any answers either
but just to have somebody that you know
I could at least get it off my chest I
was like what you know we're in a spiral
like and he's like you're a spy it was
like okay I was like you know and here
are they I think we have like two shots
to get out and here they are and you
know and that just just at least talking
it through and not feeling like I was
missing anything but you know I think a
lot of people now they meditate and do
other kinds of things and so forth and I
you know I I would wrapped it up but it
you know it that's you know that's not
what I did at the time so he's like
sweating it out like cut years off of my
life and all that kind of thing it
strikes me that one of your superpowers
may be running towards the scary things
and not away from the scary things which
might result in a lot of acute
short-term to rest but it may ultimately
result in less long-term duress could
you explain the line sharpen your
sharpen the contradictions yes this is
the line I think this was from actually
originally Karl Marx and he was speaking
of the you know sharpen the
contradictions between capital and labor
and you know to basically accelerate the
rebel
um and you know I definitely think Lenin
used it because you know Lenin was like
amazing with rhetoric and and that kind
of thing he was definitely a rhetorical
genius he also kind of wrong about
everything and had a horrible impact on
the world but like that's a different
story
but what I like to use it in management
because it's a great kind of cue for the
CEO because what happens in an
organization is like you'll see like
little disagreements between people and
like a lot of your inclination is to
like smooth things over but the right
answer is usually to sharpen the
contradictions and the reason you want
to sharpen the contradictions is because
that's there's information in that
contradiction there's information about
like how you're not communicating how
the objectives are not aligned how the
strategy might be wrong and like you've
got to get that because that's where the
truth is and so when you smooth that
over if you don't like bring it to a
head and resolve it then you know you
miss an opportunity so it really is you
know it's one of the most important
techniques I think and that anytime like
in a board meeting anytime like I hear
like a little bit of disagreement or I
see like you know an inconsistency in
the strategy Iowa that's always my cue
to myself I wanna you know that's when
you get the answer now it's also a good
way to start a revolution so you gotta
be careful see so you are not a fan of
the the default revolution no well maybe
that too but I was gonna say you're not
you're not a fan of the default
backpedaling oh no it's a
miscommunication that type of it maybe
but like it's probably a systemic
miscommunication you know I mean and as
opposed to like oh yeah like you met
this and you meant that and like so now
we're all happy yeah that's not what
happened
very rarely
you uh you have a new book why write a
new book I mean you're a gifted writer
but why write a new book and why this
book um could you describe could you
describe what it is so yeah so in and
that's a great question because after I
wrote the last one I was like I'm never
writing another one that goes nope so it
surprised me but you know it's
interesting because when I was kind of
first learning to be a CEO one of the
you know and I asked I asked Bill and I
asked a lot of kind of others mentors
like you know what should I focus on and
you know a lot of them said you know you
should focus on culture but then I said
well how do I do that
and nobody really had any kind of like
it was all these weird abstract ideas
that didn't they weren't compelling you
know they weren't well articulated and I
never you know it was always like a
grope in the dark for me to try and
understand like how to set the culture
how to change it and so I really kind of
became obsessed with this question for
myself and you know I did a lot of even
in my life I've kind of been interesting
about like culture and the broader sense
and so you know I just really really
really spent a lot of time kind of going
through you know history going through
kind of trying to understand how people
did it like what were the components and
it turns out to be a you know I think
one of the most central parts of
Management and that if you think about
like management tools you know there's
the mission statement and there's the
okrs and KPIs and you've got you know
whatever your objectives and you've got
you know all these kinds of things but
none of them really dictate the things
that really define who you are right
like you show up on time for meetings
you stay at the Four Seasons you stay at
the Red Roof
do people go home at 5:00 or they go
home at 8:00 you know like what kind of
company is this what are all those
behaviors to get back to people like
right away or do you never get back to
them or you get back to them in three
days and like all of those behaviors
like are your culture but they're how
people are behaving when you're not
looking so like what do you do about
that and you know how do you set that
and how do you make that go because that
ultimately is really going to speak that
lis to the quality of your company but
like what impression it makes on the
world right like is it a good company to
do business with us at a bad company is
it a place where people work and their
life becomes better is it what place
they work in their life becomes worse
you know like what are all these things
and they're all a result of this like
weird abstract saying call it culture
and so you know as I started working
with CEOs like of course none of them
know really how to deal with it at all
like they have ideas but most of the
ideas are like half-baked and like
mostly wrong so I thought you know I
should really go back and re study this
problem and see if I can articulate it
and that's what the books about
and ice called what you do is who you
are because it's not what you believe
it's not your values it's not what you
tweet it's not like your social signal
it's like what you actually do that's
who you are
and once you get your head around that
you realize that's a big task and the
the subtitle is how to create your
business culture and you I think alluded
to at least one big component of this
but is culture then as you define it
here like a shared set of behaviors and
beliefs or how would you suggest people
who are listening to this perhaps change
how they think about culture or ask
themselves questions that will help to
refine their thinking if they're CEOs or
founders of a company for instance yeah
so the and one of the greatest most
longest-lasting kind of cultures and
histories is
way of the warrior the culture of the
samurai you know and you can like that
culture or not but you have to give the
credit for the fact that it lasted like
over a thousand years and to hold a
culture for that long is amazing
and one of the key insights from Bushido
is a culture is not a set of beliefs
it's a set of actions and that's really
what the culture is and this is why I
think people miss it so much because
they think it's a shared set of beliefs
but it's not it's a shared set of
behaviors and you don't even have to
believe it but if you behave that way
that's a culture and this is and you
know what you have to ask yourself is
okay like what are the behaviors that
show like for real that we're doing what
we believe and I'll just give you an
example in venture capital every venture
capital firm says they have great
respect for the entrepreneurs right very
few treat entrepreneurs with any kind of
respect at all and so you go like well
how do you have that disconnect and it's
because they haven't defined like what
are the actions that translate into that
being a real thing in a real part of the
culture and so you know this is one of
the like the problems we have to solve
when we started the firm and one of the
things I you know one of the things I
put in place very early on was like if
you're late for a meeting with an
entrepreneur I collected $50 today on
this you know it's $10 a minute and
people like well what if I had to go to
the bathroom I don't care you know what
if you had to make a phone call and I'm
Karen and the reason I have it that way
is because I want them to ask me well
why and when they say why I say because
like building a company is really really
hard and you know if an entrepreneur
takes time out of their day to come see
us like we're going to respect the fact
that that how hard it is and we're
always going to be on time no excuses
plan your day finish that phone call
five minutes before you have to meet
with the entrepreneur goat
the bathroom earlier don't drink that
eighth cup of coffee you know like but
you need to do what you're supposed to
do and you know you have to set these
kinds of things in place if you're
really going to live up to your ideals
and and that has to be across every
dimension of the culture you have to
kind of program it in or you're just not
going to have it you know you're gonna
talk it and then if you talk it and
don't do it then your culture becomes
your hypocrisy right is it is is culture
something that you really have to get
right at the get-go or is it possible to
do a rehaul and make it work without
replacing all of the employees at a
company yeah no you definitely can
change the culture you definitely can
change calls yeah yeah my actually two
two of my favorite examples in the book
are one the Haitian Revolution where you
know lower chair reprogrammed slave
culture into a military culture which is
almost unfathomable in that like now I
did he have a slave culture but it was
one of the most difficult slave culture
it was a significantly more brutal kind
of slave environment than even like the
u.s. slave environment so if you've from
the beginning of kind of the
transatlantic slave trade to the Haitian
Revolution I think nine hundred thousand
slaves were brought to Haiti at the end
there were four hundred sixty-five
thousand left at the start of the
Revolution in the u.s. five hundred
thousand slaves were brought in that
same period and there were seven hundred
thousand left so like it was like that
much quantitatively that much more
brutal so a very difficult environment
of low trust to build like a military
force and you know he built him he built
a culture that you know created an army
that defeated you probably at least two
of the strongest military European
military powers in history you know
France under Napoleon and
that British Empire and so you got to
say absolutely you can change the
culture and you know he used the same
guys the same guys who were kind of
slaves didn't even have clothes that
kind of thing - you know - that kind of
army and then the other one that I found
very interesting is Shaka Senghor who is
running you know a prison gang a very
violent prison gang
yeah and changed the culture to be like
remarkably you know empathetic for it
you know it's still prison gang so like
it wasn't all friendly but it was a
really significant change and those guys
you know I have met some of those guys
you know that he had there as they've
gotten out of prison and it's just
remarkable the effect it had on them not
only in that organization but but coming
out so 100% it's possible and in either
case in in the former that is is at
least based on my very limited
understanding was if not the only one of
the only successful slave revolutions
yeah exactly the only the only slave
revolt in human history that ever
resulted in an independent state what
were any of the things that he did that
helped with that transformation from
slave culture to sort of organized
military culture yeah so it you know
he's a quite a remarkable guy along
these lines in that he was born a slave
so - Sam was born a slave but he was so
smart that the plantation owner
basically made - sent not only he let
him read so he learned to read and we
read things like Caesar's commentaries
where he learned a lot of his military
strategy and some economics books and so
forth but he also made him his driver
and so - Sant was able to go to all
these meetings you know on the island
till he learned French colonial culture
kind of
Roman military culture and then he'll
sinews slave cultures so he had this
really comprehensive cultural
understanding so he knew the elements of
kind of the various things that that he
wanted and so one of the one of the
techniques he used which I refer to as
kind of create a shocking rule was he
had to solve this problem that trust was
super low I mean the most difficult part
of slave culture is it lacks trust and
the reason is Trust is really like a
long-term commodity and that I'm gonna
do something for you today because I
trust that over time like it's gonna pay
off for me but if you're a slave there's
no tomorrow
right there you have no possessions they
could take your family at any point they
can kill you at any point you don't own
your own life so to build trust in that
environment is almost impossible the way
to say I did it is you know or one of
the ways he does create this role which
was basically officers can't cheat on
their wives and you think about that you
go okay well maybe that's not that big a
deal but like you're talking about an
environment where like basically
soldiers were paid in like raping and
pillaging like that that was like a
fundamental a kind of thing that
everybody did outside of Tucson sir me
but he said no look I need to be able
like your word like is everything and he
had a great line about you know he'd
rather relinquish his command and break
his word that's how much emphasis he put
on it and like if I can't trust you to
keep that one promise them you can't be
an officer in the army and so everybody
wanted to know why that rule was in
place and so that kind of starts to
build up okay here's how much we value
you keeping your word and so that was
you know kind of one like little aspect
that he did to reset the culture you
know another thing was he he really
elevated ethics and you go well like why
is that important well you know
live with a higher code and you have a
stronger bond because it gives you a
feeling about yourself and a feeling
about the people who you're working with
that like we're doing something
important and you know one thing and he
out liked that end he outlawed raping
and pillaging in the army
and he said look we're after something
more important and that's Liberty and so
we're not going to rape at pillage and
it became so powerful that the white
women in Haiti referred to sent as
father like this is a slave who's
running an army they like him better
than the troops from Spain or Britain or
France they they've loved like the the
slave army better because they treated
them so much better and and there's a
great story around this witch and it's a
legend so you know it's one of those
ones we don't know is true but the name
- sound overture he wasn't born he was
born to sin because slaves only had a
first name it was part of the
dehumanization process and L'Ouverture
came later and nobody knows for sure why
but the story is you know Napoleon hated
him like he drove Nepal crazy
Napoleon suffered more casualties in
Haiti than in Waterloo and he wanted to
get him so badly and he got his generals
around he said like how can you not
defeat this slate and the general said
well we get him backed up we surround
him but every time we think we have him
there is an opening and so his name is
Toussaint L'Ouverture
Toussaint the opening and you know I at
least i belief is that you know those
people those those women in the town you
know they helped him in a way that like
Napoleon could never understand because
he had elevated the culture to that
degree so you know those are a couple of
things I'm gonna go on for her obviously
hours and hours and hours on the Haitian
Revolution yeah fascinating I mean this
is something I knew nothing about before
doing some homework for this
conversation and
I'm excited for but hopefully the
clarity and with that precise action
that the book will bring to something
that like you said culture and quotation
marks is often thrown around as a
collection of very high altitude
abstract concepts but with without any
real plausible next steps but this this
really makes the abstract concrete or it
seems seems that way that you're both
giving examples historical and current
day of how to install these these shared
and in some cases rewarded behaviors yes
definitely definitely that's uh ya know
that's why I'm so excited about the book
I mean I just feel particularly now and
you know you see all these criticisms of
high tech culture and like you know this
CEO how could he run a company like this
and so forth
and and whenever I see that I'm like
well it's really hard it's really hard
to get you know ten thousand people to
behave the way you want them to and you
know like the default is everybody's
culture I screwed up and it takes a lot
of effort to make it good yeah it makes
me think of the there's a ram das quote
which I'll paraphrase but it's something
along the lines of if you think you're
enlightened to go spend a week with your
family and it's like okay like like
everybody should reflect on that when
they're criticizing a especially I would
say a relatively unseasoned or new to
the job CEOs ability to get 10,000
people to behave well it's very
difficult it's very very very very very
challenging what what would you consider
success for this book what type of
outcomes would you like to see in the
world
that's a great question it's funny
because when I wrote the first one my
goal was that the CEOs and the portfolio
would read it and that turned out to be
a good goal because it was so narrow
that I think it forced me to write a
specific book which I think a lot more
people like
you know in this one I would you know I
think that anybody who who kind of cares
about their imprint on the world you
know this is kind of the book for that
in that and I always tell the people out
the firmness look you know when we're
all retired like we're not going to
remember like every deal that we did
that was good or that we did that was
bad or that we want or that we lost her
you know how much money we made her any
of that but we're gonna remember like
what it felt like to work there and what
it felt like for the people who
interacted with us and and like we're
gonna know if we were proud of it or
like it's something we want to forget
and that you know that's what culture is
really about it's like who are you like
what do you do like you know what does
it mean to know you and that you know I
I think it's such an important thing but
people don't have the mechanics for that
or the you know that I hadn't been able
to find anything that I could read on
that so that that's kind of the purpose
of the book and you know I really like
that it also it I would imagine and I
haven't yet read the book but I'm very
excited to that it that it provides
examples that allow people to see
principles in action and sort of deduce
how those might apply to to their own
decisions whether that's say you know
Reed Hastings write at Netflix or
Netflix or rewinding the clock and going
all that all the way back to jenga's
Khan is of course I shouldn't say of
course but it's not was someone that
I've been really fascinated with for the
last few years for many many reasons and
has been really portrayed in a lot of
the coverage in a one-sided sort of
one-dimensional a very unfairly but
these sort of the scale is underrated
very underrated and the vision of
cultural inclusiveness that you talk
about in the book is it relates to that
I think it will be really I
opening to people and I'm excited about
it for that reason I know we're coming
up on time be fun to grip you know grab
a coffee and around to some other time I
still have a long list of questions
which which which we can get to some
other time
but let me ask just a couple of really
quick closing questions and then bring
this to a wrap but the this question is
is sometimes one that is difficult to
answer but I'll lob it out there and see
what we get and that is if you had a
billboard this is a metaphor of course
but a billboard on which you could put a
anything you want an image a question a
word a quote but it allows you to get a
convey something to billions of people
not non-commercial what can you can you
think of anything that you might put on
such a billboard so this is just really
off the top of my head because I was
listening to this song this morning but
my friend nas has this great line which
is I know you think I'm rich because of
my diamond piece but I've been rich
since I started finding peace mm and I
think that's that's my best my vibe
today well that that could be a podcast
in and of itself just digging into that
because my diamond piece but all right
all right
finding piece that will be part of our
of our around - is there anything else
in terms of closing comments suggestions
recommendations asks of the audience
that that you'd like to add before we
before we close up this first
installment at least it yeah I think
that what I would just say is the book
is really you know to enable you to do
what you need to do kind of as a leader
and as organization to be
you want to be and as a leader I think
that's the most important thing
wonderful that is what you do is who you
are you can find that anywhere books are
sold
people can wave hello on the internet on
Twitter at B Horowitz and we'll link to
that and everything else in the show
notes including everything that we
mentioned so people listening can find
that at tim dot blog forward slash
podcast been this has really been a lot
of fun and very and lightning and
enlivening and i have all sorts of notes
to follow up on for my own research and
reading and so thank you so much for
taking the time i really really
appreciate it and I thank you and I'm
looking forward to round two and the cup
of coffee deal hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email for me every Friday is that
provides a little morsel of fun for the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek comm all
spelled out and just drop in with your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin's hello Monday hello Monday is
a podcast
hello Monday with Jessie Hempel is back
for season 2 and the show is full of
advice practical tactical advice that
you can start using today each week
Jesse sits down with featured guests to
investigate the role work plays in their
lives how it can be integrated into your
life and how to make work work for you
better this season one of the first
episodes is with sherry Colonna who has
been called the CEO whisperer I've
actually done quite a bit of work with
Terry and he is one of the world's most
in-demand executive coaches amongst the
startup ecosystem in the episode Jerry
shares his person meetings explains how
to ask good open-ended questions and he
also goes through his áfirstá daily
journal a among other things journaling
can really create an incredible
competitive advantage and also act as an
emotional rebalancing tool of sorts so I
recommend taking a look at it giving a
listen more accurately so whether you're
starting your first job or gearing up
for retirement
hello Monday helps you tackle Monday and
the rest of the work week with tactics
and strategies that you can use so check
it out
fine hello Monday with Jesse temple
that's Jes sh t enpe L fingers look up
hello Monday on Apple podcast or
wherever you listen to podcasts this
episode of the Tim Ferriss show is
brought to you by athletic greens I get
us all the time if I could only take one
supplement what would it be
the answer is inevitably athletic greens
I view it as and a lot of you now view
it as all in one nutritional insurance I
recommended it way back in 2010 in the
4-hour body and I did not get paid to do
so I've been using it since before that
and I use it in a lot of different ways
I travel with it to avoid getting sick
or to help mitigate the likelihood of
getting sick I take it in the morning to
ensure optimal performance and overall
it covers my bases if I can't get what I
need from whole food meals throughout
the rest of the day and if you want to
give athletic greens a try they're
offering a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I nearly always travel
with at least three or four of these one
in other words if you buy athletic
greens as a first-time buyer you now get
for a limited time and extra $79 in free
product so check out the details at
athletic greens com forward slash Tim
again that's athletic greens dot-com
forward slash Tim for your free travel
pack with any purchase
[Applause]